do you mean can you tell me more about  the difference between commitment and  marriage  well commitment is your is your personal  decision to be committed to one to an  individual or anything and that uh  doesn't have to be that one person  um it  being committed means you're committed  to this thing so if it's a relationship  you're committed to that relationship if  you're committed to your job whatever  it's you're committed to it marriage  um is taking on extra  uh characterizations to support  the things that come along with that so  um if you have a family marriage it  helps you whether it be taxes or  um household environment stability there  are benefits to come with it that's  always been the case with marriage